a rat done bit my sister
n with Whitey on the moon her face and
arms began to
swell and whes on the
moon I can't pay no doctor bill but
whities on the Moon 10 years from now
I'll be paying
still while whes on the
moon when the Great American poet and
musician Gil Scott Heron wrote those
words in 1970 50 years ago now
inequality in the United States was
bad but it was not nearly as bad as it
is
today the Us and other countries such as
the UK had experienced unprecedented
narrowing of wealth gaps over the mid
20th century how through policies that
are the same ones as the ones called for
by the motion today through abolishing
the entitlements that wealthy
millionaires had until citizens and
their governments said we will no longer
be survi
to wealth
plutocrats and I suspect that from my
opponent you might hear a similar phrase
abolish
wealth but with a different emphasis the
idea of abolition might be condemned as
an act of violence it will be seen like
an unfair overstretch of government the
very notion seems like an attack on
billionaire freedom to make money
however they want want regardless of the
cost to others to gift it however they
want to bequeath it however they want to
use their
power to reinforce the power of their
heirs until you get to the stage where
40% of all
wealth in a nation like the United
States is inherited wealth just as it is
today a nation where much like in the UK
poverty is rising and life expectancy is
declining in many
regions a nation where a
billionaire like Jeff Bezos the richest
man in the world can pay zero federal
income
tax and not only does he rarely pay any
tax but in 2011 his tax burden was so
low that he was eligible for a $4,000
child tax credit and he took it
of course he took it just like he is
taking from the workers his workers
their right to organize for better
livelihoods just like he took tax
dollars to boost himself into space good
thing he did claim that child credit
when you think about it though because
surely he needed it for say
food you fuel to get to space because
certainly it wasn't his own Ingenuity or
knowhow getting him there the technology
was already funded
by democratic governments the same
governments that my opponent and his
friends at the KO Institute think are so
useless and you know what lately they're
right lately governments have been
useless at the key Criterion the
Baseline stipulation that Enlightenment
thinkers like Adam Smith saw as the
fundamental duty of a civilized and a
accountable government the ability to
make the rich pay their fair share Smith
makes this point in Wealth of Nations
where he he sharply criticizes tax
systems in earlier feudal times because
as he saw
it they let the rich get away with gross
abuses of
power back then he writes to quote the
Sovereign was obliged to content himself
with taxing those who were too weak to
refuse taxation like the rich
did only a barbaric preil Society he
pointed out places the biggest
proportionate burden on a society's
weakest groups while allowing the rich
to thumb their noses at
governments which is why it's kind of
funny when people from the KO Institute
uphold Smith to talk about say Market
freedom for Smith true Freedom meant an
end to the barbaric Privileges and gross
impunity of the excessively rich and how
do you end those
privileges simple you you abolish them
you abolish billionaire power which is
what this motion calls for just like it
was once necessary to reign in the
absolute power of feudal monarchs and
overlords to
abolish their control over the people we
must abolish the power of economic
overlords today continued civilization
this is an existential threat continued
civilization and Enlightenment depend on
on it thank
you excellent thank you very much
Lindsay um that was slightly under time
actually I'm pleased to say need any
remaining minutes right but let's go
straight to you
Ryan oh sorry my apologies let me
introduce you first of course our
speaker against the motion is Ryan
Bourne the r Evans sha chair for the
public understanding of Economics at the
K Institute he's a regular public
commentator on the economy an author of
an excellent book economics in one virus
an introduction to economic reasoning
through Co 19 which was recently named a
financial times summer read the
2021 so now Ryan over to you for your
six
minutes well take two uh thank you so
much to Ben and to intelligence Square
for the opportunity to debate this
motion abolish billionaires I mean
you've got to admire the candidness of
that title relative to the sorts of tech
ratic things I usually debate and I
really do understand the Instinct here
because I used to agree with a professor
you see Jeff bezos's massive new mansion
here in DC or Richard Branson and him
firing themselves into space then you
read about poverty and misery and
homeless people worldwide and I think
it's really seductively easy to make
that intellectual leap that the poverty
of the poor must in some way be a
consequence of the wealth of the rich or
at the very least that we of course in
the form of government usually could
simply take from the wealthy and spend
that money better and it's true if you
look at any list of global billionaires
uh some did make their fortunes from the
sorts of unjust cronyism that Adam Smith
railed against whether it's Carlos Slim
and The Mexican telecom's Fortune the
Russian oligarchs or even elong musk
getting states to compete to offer Tesla
special tax breaks that sort of crony
capitalism governments granting
privileges like restrictive intellectual
property or or even subsidies that does
push some people's wealth up and make
some people billionaires that sort of
deck tilting by government makes us
poorer it diverts resources to
unproductive Ventures it encourages
lobbying and I oppose it in all its
forms and I spend much of my time at
Kato arguing against it but the truth is
the majority of billionaires in the US
and UK today didn't get wealthy from
government favors most in fact got
extremely rich by providing the ideas
leadership or capital for products that
we as customers vote with our wallets to
buy because we value them uh WhatsApp
Founders Brian Acton and Jason K founded
a company in a really globally
competitive instant messaging industry
they grew the business it's now two and
a half billion people in over 180
countries the WhatsApp app generates 5
to 10 billion dollars a year in annual
revenue so when those Founders sold up
to Facebook they were of course rewarded
with a cool combined 15 billion dollar
for their Innovation they didn't rent
seek their apparent crime deserving of
abolition was just to create a trusted
product that slashed the cost
dramatically for millions of people
around the world to stay in contact with
their loved ones and as Economist
William nordhouse has said of
entrepreneurs Who deliver similar
transformative Innovation their riches
might look huge in absolute terms but
that's a mere Slither of the huge
consumer value they created so why
should their weal wealth be now
plundered and treated as if they're the
same as Carlos Slim or a Russian
oligarch how can we talk about
billionaires as if they're a common
class of people ignoring how those
individuals made their money and if you
think I'm cherry picking an example on
the source of billionaire wealth the
wealthiest 20 people in the world right
now includes those associated with
founding Amazon Google Microsoft Walmart
Facebook Zara and Nike in Britain it's
Dyson inos home Bargains the vast
majority of billionaires wealth remains
in productive business assets just 2% is
in personal property like houses and
Yachts so what would happen if we
abolish billionaires well clearly one
effect would be we disincentivize The
Innovation that got people like this
rich in the first place now nobody says
that wealth is the only motivator for
entrepreneurs and I can't get in their
heads but the desire to have billions in
funds whether it's to keep score to
reinvest uh to provide for your heirs or
even to play Global savior clearly does
matter to some business people and as
The Economist Charles Jones has pointed
out we only need that sort of wealth
confiscation or very high taxes to deter
a very few major Innovations by reducing
that uh payoff to be really socially
destructive and given this wealth is
impr productive business assets what
would taxing it or taking it away do
force them to sell their companies
encourage them to give wealth away to
political interest groups with actual
power incentivized blowing it on
consumption like space races that people
apparently dislike and for what benefit
when we get the revenue more money for
Boris Johnson to spend on Royal Yachts
or dodgy bridges in the north for
context confiscating Jeff bez's entire
wealth would fund the US federal
government for just 11 days who do you
even think would use those billions to
enrich your lives more through
reinvestment or philanthropy business
people like Jeff Bezos or Bill Gates or
politicians like Boris Johnson and
Donald Trump to ask the question I think
is to answer it now at this stage
somebody usually says put all that aside
but nobody deserves a billion dollars so
let's consider a thought experiment
let's imagine a world where everyone was
equally productive earned the same
income paid the same taxes there was
perfect
equality suddenly one person in that
Society comes up with a brilliant idea
for an appliance that could transform
your life Life by say cleaning your
house automatically with no human input
whenever it got dirty so brilliant a
product in fact that everybody in the
world wants one and buys
one as a result of that Innovation the
owner the founder of that company would
probably end up a comfortable
billionaire what message would we send
by then confiscating this wealth and
redistributing it to maintain equality I
contend that most billionaires do make
their money through this sort of honest
value creation that dis incentivizing
that process is a bad idea and that
actually letting markets not governments
and not the professor allocate wealth
has coincided with the huge enrichment
of society in the past two centuries so
yes let's discuss let's agree on
removing unfair government favors that
enrich the wealthy but abolishing all
billionaires by plunder that's a really
foolish
proposition